6 heures
dégagé
ces leçons d'un appareil photo qui est
aujourd'hui presque disparu un indice
par les temps qui courent il ya quelques
acteurs actrices et chanteuses qui
aimeraient sans doute vous faire que
prendre quelques clichés compromettants
avec cet appareil les plus perspicaces
où les plus vieux auront reconnu le
polaroid qui se trouve aujourd'hui
vraiment au cimetière des gadgets dont
johnny qu'on ne va pas nécessairement
l'enterrer complètement comme je vais
vous le dire surtout pas avec ce qui
s'est passé cette semaine parce que il
ya des photos coquines qui ne se
seraient pas retrouvés
donc dans le nuage informatique si elle
avait été réalisée avec un polaroïd
durée dans une boîte à chaussures à
dessus du lit en dessous du gué du lit
ou dans le garage avec l'invention
recette spéciale et on ce n'est pas une
tranche de vécu ici en coop peut-être
que son étude n'est pas la mienne donc
je vous rappelle que le polaroïd ou ce
qu'on appelle la pareille à
développement instantané il été inventé
à la fin des années 40 à ce moment là
vous vous en doutez bien et est
monochrome
puis il est devenu en couleurs des
années 60 pour atteindre son apogée
années 70-80 notamment vous vous en
rappellerez peut-être avec les
publicités en anglais de james green day
avec un couple avec une femme et et nous
lançons jour-là mal de mes l'autre et en
français on avait sacha distel on all
écoute un peu
autant la chance c'est un cadeau
fantastique voilà un an et demi le plus
un produit - eh bien je vais voir si
c'est peut-être aller va nous regarde ça
se développe tout seul en quelques
minutes vous avez la charge ou une
petite idée derrière tout ça ok les
photographes professionnels vont les
utiliser donc pour les tests le monde
médical ou si oui bien sûr mais le
polaroïd va connaître son waterloo avec
l'arrivée bien sûr de la photo numérique
comme toute la photo argentique mais il
reste quand même des irréductibles
c'est le cas de jean françois dupuis qui
photographe à sherbrooke et qui utilise
encore et toujours un polaroïd notamment
pour son côté beaucoup plus sensuelle si
on veut que les appareils numériques
j'ai parlé ce matin commence à
fonctionner dans le polar est vraiment
pour faire des terres après ça on
travaillait pellicule exemple on n'est
pas rendus aux familles en portrait ou
pour vérifier notre éclairage
enfin pas la run on regarde la polarized
qui à présent à partir du polar eyedea
les lanières est bonne le après sont pas
s'impliquer
maintenant c'est le contraire je dois
faire beaucoup de photographies
numériques et quand je vois quelque
chose pour sip 1 au pas les rebelles ne
formant pas les rues vous sortez votre
polaroïd encore aujourd'hui oui c'est
quoi la réaction des français les uns
première mère c'est la fin les gens font
toujours un aimant
peut-être pas l'avant et alentours de 35
dollars c'est un séchage donc moins les
parages utilise pas pour faire n'importe
quoi comme une vieille martin lapostolle
mais quand on l'a fait on sait que ça va
nous coûter des sous les quelque chose
de nostalgique a juste appuyer sur le
déclencheur du polaroïd le brut ça fait
c'est pas pareil comme le numérique
l'eau c'est vraiment et c'est andré
comme de quoi de magic s'est incliné à
chaque fois maintenant avec le numérique
les jeunes ont le photo il regarde ce
sont leurs lors leur appareil leur
iphone jeu des six lots mais un impact
pour le tri le plaisir de toucher ou pas
l'arrêt de patrick pop art on fait venir
et qu'on fait de manière forte houle
je vais même c'est le contraire on ne
trouble il faut penser mais plus qu est
ce qui est bon que ce n'est pas bon
indiquant qu'on travaille ou pas la rue
dont on leur prend le temps d'analyser
quelles sont vos saisir notre image
mais
deux mots clés de la voir apparaître
toujours toujours un spectacle pour moi
il ya quelque chose que j'ai pu
si on fait des photos numériques on
gagne si on en vient comme un peu
glauque vraiment le papier l'image
apparaît qu'il est la chimie pc moi
j'adore ça c'est vraiment un cauchemar
que je me donnerais jamais de temps
maintenant je fais une photo admirer une
faute en pas le rush des polémiques
d'action remains évidemment que le
polaroïd me permet de prouver que c'est
encore un bon photographe maintenant
aussi avec le numérique tout le monde
s'improvise photographes et les gens
souvent ils font des photos qui sont
tout photographe on a juste regarder sur
facebook qui tout le monde est
photographe
mes photos guerre c'est un métier qui
sautille et plat donc en faisant du
polaroïd joseph et c'est là qu'on voit
que la personne l ue poule c'est moi
j'ai besoin de toi pour me prouver que
c'est encore un d'un côté de recherche
p-dg de travail à stx
jacques lemaire nous
merdique et comment il fait pour se
procurer des films ou des appareils
justement parce que ça existe à peu près
plus maintenant les appareils au peut
encore en trouver sur ebay et la petite
lucie et dans certains cas ça va vous
coûter seulement une dizaine de dollars
pour les films ils sont en vente sur
internet depuis que des anciens employés
de quoi la rue dont relancer
l'entreprise nouveau nom impossible
project vraiment un projet possible il
faut savoir qu'un appareil transforme
votre téléphone
un polaroïd en permettant d'imprimer sur
le champ vos photos oui monsieur mais ça
s'appelle instant lab in the clouds et
de la compagnie hasbro project ou si on
va vous mettre l'ailier sur la page
facebook de l'émission met donc c'est ça
existe encore du film paul heureux oui
mais vous avez entendu 35,40 dollars
pour 8 photos donc vous avez intérêt à
être certain qu'elle soit bonne foi
beaucoup merci beaucoup j'ai un câble et
un prix au revoir